wartungs seite gesehen oder event seite
da gibt es noch eine seite events da war
das auch angezeigt also ich weiß dass
vera und und der soll ihn wahr ab juli
warten
was kann ich sagen was kann ich machen
jetzt 17
schon fünf minuten vor diese treffen
haben sie schon gesagt wir warten wir
freuen uns und jetzt warten sie können
einen kommentar schreiben
von sorgen dass sie aufs kicken müssen
und dann sehen sie die mitteilung für
echt okay das ist eine endliche man
sieht dass hier auch wir sind jetzt zwei
okay dann wäre
juli sie ritten ohne umlaut weil ich
habe keine wir müssen was machen auf hj
klicken will kann auf der linken seite
auf die linke seite und mit handlichen
auf die linken seite okay
bis bald wir warten auf euch und wir
warten
ok also sonst du ich gehe das ist er ja
ich kenne ich schon ans pferd aber wer
will kann das ein bisschen über die ich
selbst also erklären
ja ich wohne in england im osten
englands und ich lerne
deutsch französisch und ein bisschen
chinesisch ich lerne deutsch seit vier
jahren in der schule und an seit drei
jahren im selbststudium also natürlich
habe ich nicht so viel in der schule
gelernt aber sie haben sprachen
vorgestellt vielleicht auf und jetzt
lerne ich sehr gern deutsch und ich
benutze link und mehrere website und ja
es ist am sonntag ich versuche auch
viele die aus anzuschauen und mein
verständnis zu verbessern
ganz fantastisch nicht sagen ich bin
begeistert juli zu gratulieren
also ich weiß dass du da warst schon 25
minuten vor diese treten
warum hat es so lange gedauert ich will
dieses system verstehen also ich war ein
und dann muss ich also warten und ich
warte war die oderstädter haben beide
februar an kommt niemand
und dann du bist ganz spät gekommen
warum ist das wifi ist das sicher ich
hatte auf den dialog geschaut wo dann
die verschiedenen bootsmann man ungefähr
elf pos und da hatte ich erwartet dass
da die einladung kommt und da kam die
einleitung ladung nicht haben dann bin
ich wieder auf die linke google+ seite
gegangen und dann habe ich da die
einladung gesehen ich habe sicher sieben
bis zehn minuten dadurch verpasst und
ich war ich das wäre auch wartet wir
machen dann wäre
du kannst
ja das habe ich gemacht das werde ich
noch einmal machen kann weil ich ich
weiß nicht wie sie wartet okay du hast
du aber lebt in england und deutschland
und spricht sehr sehr ich benutze
mehrere systemen aber vielleicht einigen
monaten 30 linke das ist eine
fantastische möglichkeit viele artikel
zu finden mit audio und das ist wichtig
finde ich und mein französisch ist nicht
so gut und deswegen konzentrieren
ein bisschen mehr auf französisch und
ich höre sehr gern war mein verständnis
in französisch nicht so gut ist also ist
es ist ein guter system
ich bin im internet mehr unter dem namen
fast zu dir bekannt aber ich weiß
julien und wohne in deutschland an der
niederländischen grenze und deswegen
spricht so auch glücklich und
niederländisch nein ich hatte vor 30
jahren an der universität hatte ich
niederländisch gelernt also ich hab
schon 30 jahre erfahrung mit dieser
sprache
also wir werden beginnen also ich weiß
nicht ob sie etwas tun kann
also wäre zu zu hilfen aber ich es tut
mir leid weil der ich weiß dass sie
wartet ich weiß nicht wie was man ich
habe einige male kommentare ich nicht
hören
hallo hallo hallo hallo ich nicht ich
höre nicht auf das hat sie hat jetzt das
gleiche problem wahrscheinlich was nicht
im erst beim ersten mal hatte sie muss
das audio richtig einstellen auf
kopfhörer wenn sie ein kopfhörer trägt
dich dinge dass wir mehr müssen müssen
lernen müssen ein bisschen erfahren weil
ich finde diese google patriot ist es
sehr sehr schön benutzbar aber es gibt
immer dinge dem was man lernen muss
okay wer aber das war ja ich hätte ja ja
okay und hat fällt da wir sind da ja ich
höre alles gibt es gerade noch was ein
das zahnrad anklicken und die richtige
quelle wählen
könnt ihr mich jetzt einige mich jetzt
ja super ich benutze sonst bleibt der
weiß ich wo das alles ist aber google
hangout habe ich bis jetzt nur einmal
benutzt das ist schon ganz lange her an
speed hat auch ich wir sind ein bisschen
älter aber wir müssen auch lernen
ich war natürlich will ich den kurs die
man kein problem damit
ich habe auch kein problem damit ich es
wohl mal rausfinden wie es funktioniert
okay vielleicht werden wir uns wehren
kann
hast du ein bisschen über sich selbst er
etwas etwas sagen also eines surf
introduction sozusagen
ja was soll ich erzählen ich arbeite in
der it können
ich arbeite in der it
das heißt ich betreue bei uns in der
firma die software vor allem als ich
habe weniger mit hardware zu tun
wer mit der software und vor vier oder
fünf jahren ich weiß nicht genau habe
ich begonnen wieder englisch zu lernen
weil wir geplant hatten mal nach london
zu fahren
und naja ich hab dann irgendwie gefallen
daran gefunden in der schule habe ich
englisch mediane gemacht aber das
selbststudium hat richtig spaß gemacht
und ja dann habe ich mich im internet
umgeschaut was gibt es da hab vor allem
nach podcasts gesucht und bin darüber zu
link gekommen und hat mir gut gefallen
und irgendwann dachte ich da gibt's so
tolle lektionen so was kannst du auch
mal machen dann habe ich eine fraktion
zu erstellen für deutsch lernende und
das ist jetzt als man eigentlich mein
hobby auch noch dazu geworden neben dem
sprachenlernen jetzt jährlich noch ein
bisschen französisch
und wenn ich mehr zeit hätte würde ich
gerne noch mehr niederländisch lernen
aber moment schaffe ich das einfach
nicht weil ich privat im moment ihr
probleme habt ja okay danke schön und
hans-peter also nein
collien und dann als bild an von adam
haben wir schon gehört also juli ein
bisschen wie sag mal surf introduction
auf deutsch sich selbst vorstellen dass
sie sich selbst vor ständig voll kennt
also ich werde mich mal gerne vorstellen
und ich bin auf links seit 2009
wenn ich da aktiv bin dann höre ich mir
meistens sachen aus dem bereich spanisch
an weil ich zwar spanisch spreche aber
im realen leben mit spanisch nichts
machen kann wie benutzer als spanisch
nur im internet
ich bin jemand der das ganze leben schon
fremdsprachen lernt also ich habe sehr
früh angefangen meine erste sprache zu
lernen das war mit sieben jahren als ich
mit meinen eltern nach in die
vereinigten staaten umgezogen bin und
ich habe schon vier sprachen in der
schule gelernt und dann habe ich an der
universität st
den größten teil meiner fremdsprachen
kenntnisse erworben und ich bin eine
lebenslange lernen vor allen dingen vier
klassen unterricht also ich bin
eigentlich gar nicht der typ der selbst
lerne ich mache wenn ich selbst und
mache das nur nebenbei ergänzungs weise
also hauptsächlich mache ich amt
unterricht bin ich in abendkursen schon
seit vielen vielen jahren und ich möchte
das auch in der form gerne fortsetzen
als peter
ja bei mir so ich bin ich habe englisch
und französisch in der schule gelernt
und habt in der universität angefangen
spanisch zu lernen dann wie ich mit der
universität fertig war hab ich russland
besucht die udssr besucht und hab
russisch gelernt
dann war ich 1985 in china
danach habe ich an chinesisch zu lernen
das mache ich eigentlich noch bis heute
das ist also fast ja jetzt schon fast
fast 30 jahre könnte ich eigentlich
besser sprechen aber leider ist es nicht
so
und in letzter zeit war wir wieder so
oft nach frankreich gefahren sind und
ich frankreich eigentlich sehr liebe und
dass man gerade in frankreich braucht
man unheimlich die französischkenntnisse
weil es sonst ein bisschen schwierig ist
habe ich dann doch wieder nochmal das
französisch aus der schule aufgefrischt
naja und chinesisch läuft immer so ein
bisschen nebenher also ich setz mich da
auch nicht so sehr unter druck aber
immer wenn ich mal wieder in china oder
in taiwan war dann ja dann denke ich ja
du musst doch wieder noch ein bisschen
mehr tun und wieder ein bisschen was
machen und so weiter und so fort
also das ist so ein bisschen meine
historie bezüglich meiner sprachen und
linken habe ich das kennen gelernt das
war ist auch schon relativ lange er aber
richtig aktiv habe ich es eigentlich vor
zwei jahren benutzt da habe ich
französisch sehr intensiv gemacht hatte
auch fast 10.000 links mir
zusammengesucht und das hat mir
eigentlich unheimlich geholfen
das ist sagen aber ich mache mir immer
noch andere sachen radio oder kurse
mache ich nicht aber ich lese dann auch
mal wieder bücher also ohne link und so
weiter jetzt habe ich vor mal wieder
eine prüfung zu machen in chinesisch und
macht wieder mehr chinesisch das ist so
was ich dazu sagen kann
dran gewöhnen und wir sind sehr
denkbar für alle die lektionen der hans
peter und der julien und wer hat gemacht
finde und ich habe auch nicht viel
gemacht steve die schule kopierte immer
nur aus öffentlichen quellen
ich weiß aber es gibt beweise das ist
doch ein thema sind lektionen sind sind
erklärt die lektionen die unsere
mitglieder machen zum beispiel wäre hat
das gemacht und julien markt auch
gespräche mit wähler und auch wenn du
etwas sehr schön auf chinesisch oder
französische findet und das ist auch um
und macht ein weiterer sieht auch aber
es gibt verschiedene verschiedene weise
wie sagt man zu bereiten
okay und ich möchte sagen ich habe lange
zeit fast nie also deutsch gesprochen
deswegen ist mein deutsch also
schlechter geworden aber sowieso ich
werde versuchen das auf deutsch machen
aber sie muss ein bisschen geduld haben
okay wir haben also diesen link new
window 20 teams mit bannern und es gab
sehr viele probleme natürlich weil wir
sind keine große also unternehmen sind
einige also sehr kleine ist eine kleine
gruppe also mitarbeiter und mit die mit
der hilfe aller mitglieder haben wir das
noch ein bisschen verbessert und wir
fortsetzen die die probleme zu zugesagt
man es wären also lösen und unter
widrigen für sehr viele
also sagt man dass justins vorschläge
schläger und wir versuchen die besten
vorschläge zu integrieren also haben sie
fragen haben sie oder oder fragen sie
verstehen nicht oder sie glauben das ist
es war besser vorher wurde was sie
wollen sie haben jetzt die gelegenheit
die die also diese fragen direkt zu wehr
zuzustellen und wir können uns darüber
so entsprechen so adam
beginnen wir also auf meinen linke seite
also hast du also einige tage wo der
kommentar über linke fragen habe ich
nicht aber ich versteh ich sage link
finde ich alle winkel seine fantastische
website weiß so viele artikel mit audio
gibt und das finde ich sehr wichtig weil
man wenn man unterwegs ist kann man mit
einem ipod zu hören und das ist ja
nützlich und es ist auch nützlich weil
es verschiedene stufen gibt unter mein
vater er hat vielleicht vor einem jahr
angefangen deutsch lernen aber er hat
nicht so viel zeit aber dann wenn er bei
der arbeit ist könnte er zu hören und es
ist ja das ist fantastisch als beta ja
ich hatte ja wie das 2.0 herauskam hatte
ich eine menge meldung auch ins forum
gestellt und ich denke das bestimmt 80
bis 90 prozent inzwischen gelöst sind
aber ich würde gerne mal zwei punkte
ansprechen die ich nicht so glücklich
finde es war das erste ist die suche in
der bibliothek die ich nach wie vor
immer noch ein bisschen schwierig
empfinde ich meine auch das ist muss
sich auch gleich dazu sagen das war am
anfang schlimmer ist es inzwischen
besser geworden und trotzdem finde ich
es manchmal
nicht so ganz einfach für die mitglieder
zurück durchschauen was die einzelnen
dinge auch bedeuten also ich denke da
auch gerade an mitglieder die neu sind
zum beispiel den unterschied zwischen
playlisten und kursen
ich finde das muss man irgendwie noch
ein bisschen besser klar machen was da
eigentlich die unterschiede sind
und dann finde ich es so dass auf der
linken seite die suchmöglichkeiten jetzt
war man muss das jetzt aufklappen ja es
ist wahr ja am anfang war links das ging
ja auch bis weit nach unten konnte man
sehr viele punkte wählen
das haben sie in jetzt letzte woche
schon geändert dass man das aufklappen
muss das ist also schon ein kleiner
fortschritt aber ich will es trotzdem
ein bisschen schwieriger vielleicht kann
wäre auch noch mal was dazu sagen wie
die erfahrungen sind
der andere punkt und das ist vielleicht
für mich noch noch viel wichtiger dass
etwas was ich eigentlich bislang wurde
empfohlen was bislang im forum kaum
angesprochen wurden uns weiß dass ein
bisschen die platzverschwendung
platzverschwendung auf der seite wo
gelernt und gelesen wird das ich glaube
wäre hat auch schon mal glaube ich kurz
angesprochen und hatte probleme mit
ihren netbook und aber ich denke das ist
nicht nur eine sache der netbooks
sondern ist es grundsätzlich so dass
links und rechts vom text sehr viel
platz verschwendet wird was einfach leer
ist und ja diese box rechts wo wo auch
die wörterbücher auftauchen und die
ganzen anderen geschichten ja also es
ist wirklich so ist begeistert mich
nicht so sehr weil viele dinge
eigentlich und wichtig sind wie zum
beispiel diese diese facebook twitter
und geschichten braucht man eigentlich
beim lernen ja nicht der oder und das
ist in meinen augen platzverschwendung
und man könnte das ganze ein bisschen
straffe anordnen also enger anordnen und
damit ein bisschen platz zu haben und
der andere punkt warum mir das auch
wichtig ist ist der chinesisch lernen
muss ich immer die schrift vergrößern
das heißt ich benutze dann immer
steuerung plus oder hier auf dem mac ist
ascom anschluss um die schrift zu
vergrößern und dann habe ich da sich
dann aber alles vergrößert habe ich
genau die gleichen platz probleme von
denen wäre auch schon gesprochen hat auf
ihrem netbook letztendlich nur dass man
hier alles ziemlich groß ist aber ich
musste irgendwie die schriftzeichen ja
auch erkennen und deswegen spielt das
damit rein und ich habe da vielleicht
eine idee gibt es nicht eine möglichkeit
nur die nur den lektion stacks
vielleicht mit einer plus oder minus
taste zu vergrößern und den rest zu
vergrößern das heißt dass man in dem
style sheet irgendwie 550 geht oder so
irgendwie sowas macht also diese diese
lektion seite ein bisschen wie sagt man
auch kostbarste was man lesen dass man
die schriftgröße des textes irgendwo
noch einstellen kann oder es würde auch
für mich genügen wenn man für chinesisch
und japanisch die schrift ein bisschen
größer man die andern die anderen
sprachen da ist es ja nicht so wichtig
ach ja nicht das finde ich auch für
koreanische also dass man da vielleicht
die schrift etwas größer macht
automatisch oder per einstellung also
das war es eigentlich von einer seite
also ich werde man ich werde versuchen
ein bisschen also screen sharing zu
machen und ich werde über die bibliothek
der in die bibliothek ein bisschen wir
werden das zusammen anschauen und dann
werden
von evelyn hören und dann von bären und
dann erstmal werde ich auch auf die
seite gehen hat die linke seite gern
durch diese
auch soll screenshot wenn das alles
klappt werden wir so ich bin nicht sehr
täglich zu führen
okay okay dann hier ist diese sowie das
ist diese lernen seite
das ist dass wir beginnen alle auf diese
lernen seite ich bin nicht 100 prozent
zufrieden damit
sie müssen wissen wir haben so viele
also verschiedene also wie sagt man
ob linien aus sicht kann man sagen meine
möglichkeiten dieser lernen lernen
lernen seite das ist das hier hast du
auf die rechte seite hast du oder
empfohlenen lektionen oder empfohlenen
kurse empfohlen den playlisten und
empfohlen das heißt dass die verbraucher
also die mitglieder haben also rosen
geschenkt das meint sie ich finde diese
lektion schön und dann zum beispiel ich
habe hier auch auf die ihre interface
habe ich auf deutsch gestellt und wer
studieren jetzt spanisch ok dann hier
hat zum beispiel die sind die lektionen
die haben rollen gespielt und das ist
vielleicht wird man das interessant
finden wurde nicht okay
und er die erste frage von von
hans-peter ist diese die unterschied
zwischen playlist kurse und lektionen
ok also ich glaube die leute verstehen
lektionen das ist ein einzelheit 1
lektion der kurs das ist ich glaube
diese sind termini wie wir sind
diese in die wohnzimmer zu benutzen okay
ein kurs dass das ist viele lektionen
sie also ccc in zusammenzugehören ich
mich immer schwierig mit deutsch aber
sie gehören zusammen
ok und die kurse sind kurse die zum
beispiel in wäre macht einen kurs das
kann sein
ein podcast als kann sein einer kurs für
anfänger und dann wirst du wäre das wird
auf eine kurs also zu hören
also playlist ist ein bisschen
unterschiedlich playlist wir haben mit
gleich ist haben wir einige gedenken das
eine ist zum beispiel wenn ich blätterte
ich suche in die bibliothek und ich
finde dinge dass ich interessant finde
aber ich will das nicht sie hält nicht
jetzt studieren oder ich finde ich will
also verschiedene lektionen sammeln
dann kann ich ein playlist machen okay
das kann ich machen für mich selber oder
wenn zum beispiel ich will andere leute
hilfen dann kann er kann ich einige
lektionen dies die höheren zu zu
verschiedene kurse ich kann diese
lektionen sammeln und eine neue gruppe
erstellen und das ist ein playlist also
das ist die die diese möglichkeit freie
kurse machen aber diese sind nicht kurse
sie sind diese sind playlist und ich
kann meine playlist nur für mich an
wänden oder ich kann das veröffentlich
und das ist dies kurse für leute die
studieren chinesisch oder russisch oder
oder wahlweise was das kann sein
also denn diese sind freie einer kurs
wenn zum beispiel du magst sein kurs das
ist eine fixe also kurse playlist das
ist mehr
so wie sagt man man kann das also hier
oder für sich selbst oder für andere
mitglieder machen
okay ist das klar oder nicht so klar
darf ich mal was ergänzen den letzen
hangout mir angeguckt und da hat es tief
ja auch schon über über über die
playlist gesprochen und dann habe ich
mir gestern selber nichts war jetzt
heute morgen habe ich mir selber nimmt
eine playlist erstellt das können auch
user die können auch playlists erstellen
wobei kurse die werden nur von denen
erstellt die diese podcast produzieren
uploaded ja unsere podcast aber ich
selber war auch in der nase
daraus ein bild zu machen dann auch
anderen nutzern empfehlen oder
vielleicht war zum beispiel wenig
stellen hinaus können die auch über
mehrere kurse hinweggehen
das hat auch der vorteil du kannst sie
aus verschiedenen posen lektionen
heraussuchen und jeden zu einer playlist
zusammenstellen
ich glaube das problem ist vor allem
dass die leute mit diesen begriffen
nichts anfangen können
ich glaube der hans peter wollte auch
nur sagen er versteht es aber er glaubt
dass andere die neu zu link kommen das
nicht verstehen werden was dazu sagen
ich habe auch ein bisschen probleme gab
es am anfang wie 2.0 rauskam dass die
ganzen dinge vollkommen umbenannt werden
was früher kurs war ist jetzt eine
playlist was früher eine collection war
ist jetzt ein kurs und das hat mich am
anfang natürlich verwirrt aber was jetzt
eben für mich neu war dass man auch
privat eine playlist erstellen kann also
ist ob ich glaube ich selber noch nie
gemacht deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade
eben wieder was dazugelernt also ich
habe immer playlisten erstellt von
material was andere erstellt haben und
habe die dann quasi als
als sammlung zur verfügung gestellt also
da kannte ich das aber dass das jetzt
ich habe mich nur immer gewundert ich
benutze auch dieses ein link und da gibt
es auch ein punktuell ist und das bei
mir immer leer gewesen und habe ich mich
mal gefragt wie kann man die ein test
aber weil ich glaube ich glaube ich habe
jetzt verstanden wie das gemacht wird
also war er hat immer dazu wir haben ein
großes problem wir haben zu viele
funktionen
weil hängen und es ist an die leute
wollen nicht lesen sie wollen nicht dass
herr hilfe lesen sie wollen nicht die
kuh tutorial lesen sie wollen das
einfach verwenden und dass herr und und
aber ich muss dazu auch sagen dass die
hilfe momentan nicht nur ganz aktuell
ist das haus ist als viele dinge für uns
zu machen was wir können
wir haben nicht die leute sich einig wir
haben nicht erzählen reingestellt
ich verstehe es ist schwierig aber das
sagen okay dann hier wir haben das
mittel mit dem die blutige haben das so
gemacht
die niveau die stufe muss hier auf diese
lernen seite bestimmt werden
ok zum beispiel ich lehre lernen
spanisch und ich will in die in der
bibliothek ich bin nur mittelstufe ein
nicht dazu für zwei seen und das wird
hier bestimmt und dann wird es immer
also so bleiben in die bibliothek okay
das ist wichtig dass werden
wir haben das es ist immer die frage im
es soll das in der bibliothek bestimmt
werden oder hier auf den ländern sei der
handel das hier erwartet bildet auch
wenn das auch in die lernen seite sowie
haben uns also wir sagen erbes mit
seinen bescheidenen verschicken
es wäre hier bestimmt ok mittelstufe
okay
es war das habe ich immer falsch gemacht
ich habe immer in der bibliothek das
niveau ausgewählt und dann hat sich das
auch mal verschoben und jetzt mache ich
das will ich jetzt mal anders machen
dann wird mein problem wir haben sehr
viele probleme gemacht hat war sie
wollten also verschiedene gesagt man
bedingungen
wir wollten dass die in die bibliothek
dass das wird erinnert aber das war ein
bisschen schwierig für unser programm
programm programm wie sagt man
programmierer programmierer und wir
hatten in ihrem gefahr jetzt ist es so
und baut auf dem blutig so hier mussten
müssen sie das bestimmen wenn
mittelstufe oder beginner oder
fortschritte fortschritten und okay dass
ich glaube auf den linken seite haben
sie diese teilen meine dass wir werden
nicht darüber sprechen dann ist es auch
ein thema ok dann gerne in das wir
können oder in also empfehlen
empfohlenen lektionen wenn sie ihn auf
diese zeige alles werden sie lektionen
sehen auf wen in der bibliothek wenn sie
hier zum beispiel playlisten sehen will
dann wird werden sie alle playlisten in
der bibliothek sehe zeige alles ab oder
wenn sie meine lektionen zum beispiel
das müssen sie sie müssen sich die härte
des seit ich habe sie müssen sich
entscheiden
7 mussten sich entscheiden ich ganz
vergessen
und weil erich gewöhnlich habe hier nur
meine lektionen oder meine kurse
das ist wie ich diese seite verbrauche
ich habe immer meine lektionen hier da
weil ich finde dass bequem aber es kommt
drauf an
und wenn sie haben empfohlen zum
beispiel empfohlen
aktionen dann können sie auf die
bibliothek aber sie können auch hier auf
die bibliothek gehen meine lektion
importe und so weiter hier gehen wir zu
empfohlen lektionen dann kommen wir zu
der bibliothek ok und ihr haupt wir
haben dass er ein bisschen geändert
bibliothek das ist alle lektionen aber
nicht die lektionen die sie schon
studiert hat nur neue lektionen werden
sie auf die bibliothek findet okay oder
und wir sehen jetzt lektionen war die
können auch kurse oder playlisten sehen
aber jetzt wie wir haben das lektionen
gemacht und dann können wir oder in die
bibliothek anschauen oder meinen lag
meine lektionen die sind die lektionen
die sie studiert oder oder nur die
importe sind dinge die es von internet
importiert okay wir haben dass diese
vierte
vorher war das alles auf dieser seite
diese auf linken seite diese
verschiedene filter und wir glauben das
ist für leute die beginnen das ist ein
bisschen spiel
es ist zu viel information information
overload und dann haben die visa haben
gesagt wie sie sind ein fenster ist also
fortgeschrittene filter ein vielleicht
ist es besser also nicht diese
fortgeschrittene zu zeigen
steve darf ich da mal eine frage stellen
hier wenn man das auch klappt und zwar
niveau da sind alle sechs check boxes
sind leer
da wird jetzt nach niveau gefiltert auf
der rechten seite oder nicht
ich glaube das ist ein bank ich weiß sie
haben etwas vom freitag
ich glaube diese niveau das ist nicht
ein ernst wird das sollen wir sehen
ich verstehe nicht warum das jetzt
plötzlich inne ein weiteres zu finden
ist und die soll auch weil wir sind
jetzt auch mittelstufe ein und sei
wir sollten das sehen also ich kann ich
finde das ist ein ball so dass das war
das was ich meinte eben in meinen
bemerkungen dass das noch immer etwas
verwirrend ist und manchmal auch nicht
manchmal nicht richtig funktioniert aber
es ist ganz schon besser geworden ist
ist schon besser wenn man muss jetzt
auch das google ist gute auch mal sagen
nicht immer nur schlecht noch besser
aber ich finde das ist also ich werde
mal fragen warum findet sich diese diese
niveau wir in die entfernt fertig das
ist nicht richtig
das muss jeder sein und nennt er haben
zum beispiel ich habe von lern den
lernen welche seite dann habe ich also
mittels du für einen 2 das muss ich muss
ich hier sehen weil das sein dass sich
wie das ändern
dann muss ich hier diese möglichkeit
haben das zu ende
richtig das ist ein problem ich hatte
dazu noch ja ich hätte dazu noch einen
anderen vorschlag ich würde mir wünschen
wenn man diese filter einzeln auf
klappen könnte zum beispiel dass man
sagt ich hätte jetzt zusätzlich gern den
filter neue wörter in prozent dann
interessiert mich nicht oder ich möchte
nur den filter kategorie öffnen
das würde ich noch besser finden als das
alle filter auf einmal dann wieder
aufgehen und so kenne ich das auch von
anderen webseiten dass man die ganz
gezielt einzelne öffnen kann diese
filter und nicht alle auf einmal dann
kommen zum 2 sehr schön freut mich und
ich habe auch festgestellt dass wirklich
fehler nach sind ich glaube dass nach
einer bestimmten anzahl einträge nicht
weiter gesucht wird ich habe dort
inkonsistenzen festgestellt wenn ich
nach verschiedenen kriterien filtere das
ist bestimmt einfach nicht es fehlen
definitiv lektionen von denen ich weiß
die müssten aufgrund der filterkriterien
angezeigt werden
ja und die kommen nicht so wenn ich dann
etwas anders bilder bekommen sie also
dass das sind noch fehler tritt sind und
es wird schlimmer und es ein bisschen
besser geworden und wir werden also das
perfekt machen
aber jetzt ist es wie gesagt wir haben
diese probleme manchmal die finnen
funktioniert nicht genau
und dann werde ich hoffe wir haben die
letzte woche heraus werden noch die hand
am anfang haben wir am arm am anderen
probleme sich beschäftigt und jetzt
werden wir auch diese akte bibliothek
arbeiten bis das funktioniert direkt und
der alle bemerkungen aller alle einer
meinung sind sehr willkommen
aber ich muss eins noch doch noch sagen
du sagst die einstellung des niveaus
erfolgt auf der startseite eben gesehen
haben nun nicht hier aber ich würde doch
irgendwie vorschlagen weil das versteht
kein mensch
wo ist die grundeinstellung dass das
vielleicht doch irgendwo im profil
einzustellen ist und nicht auf der
startseite und auch nicht auf der
lektion seite sondern irgendwo im
benutzerprofil weil letztendlich der
benutzer hat eine gewisse fähigkeit und
die muss ja in seinem profil einstellen
das ist zumindest mein empfinden
das ist auch eine möglichkeit warten
gut dass wir haben darüber auch
gesprochen wir finden also desto wie
andere dinge für die leute die sich wie
sagen einschreiben
also dinge sie müssen schreiben desto
einfacher desto war sie wollen die leute
also wie sagt man sie würden nicht zu
viele nutzlasten acht überlassen sie
wollen nach so einer hand waren
es gibt noch ein problem und das ist die
leute sagen vielleicht ich bin eine
anfänger oder ich bin ein mittelstufe
lerne aber dass das ist ist das meint
dass das bedeutet nicht dass diese leute
nur zum beispiel anfänger lektionen
lernen
okay es gibt zwei dinge meinem niveau
und was ich studiere wähle okay und ich
glaube unser programm ist hat auch
gesagt es war ein problem wenn es gab zu
viel freiheit die niveau auf dem die
bibliothek ist wenn man kann das hier
bestimmen und auch in der stadt lernt
lernt er seite bestimmen und jetzt haben
die das lasso gemacht aber wir werden
hören von verschiedene leute und wir
kennen das dispositiv diskutieren und
sie werden versuchen dass das am besten
zu machen aber ich schreibe alle diese
diese vorschläge hier an und bewerten
diskutieren und versuchen das am besten
zu machen und ich ok auf die bibliothek
dann wie ich ich habe ich verstehen also
dieses soll offen sein
also werden gibt es andere probleme auf
die bibliothek auf der mitte stimmen
gibt probleme mit beschreibungen werden
nicht mehr komplett angezeigt also noch
einmal
die lektion beschreibungen werden nicht
mehr komplett angezeigt sondern nach ein
zwei zeilen abgeschnitten und in den
lektionen beschreibungen steht aber zum
beispiel oft drinne ob eine bestimmte
lizenz zum eintrag zum einsatz kommt
eine cc-by usa zum beispiel lizenz als
eine pflichtangabe die man machen muss
und diese pflichtangabe taucht nirgends
mehr auf wie sähe die auch nicht in der
lektion wenn ich die öffne in der
bibliothek sehe ich sie nicht mehr
und das wirft rechtliche probleme auf
also die lektion beschreibungen auch die
beschreibung der kurse sollte meiner
meinung nach unbedingt bei den lektionen
mit angezeigt werden entweder in der
bibliothek oder dann wenn die lektion
geöffnet wird
dort gehört sie eigentlich meiner
ansicht nach noch mit rein wir haben
deutlich die schönen informationen jetzt
ob es ein video dazu gibt oder ob es
übersetzungen gibt und genauso gehört
für mich dort hin dass man auch die
komplette lektion beschreibung sieht
also bin ich unbedingt aufnehmen
du meinst du ok wir sehen hier zum
beispiel habe einwechslung geöffnet und
wann sie denn nicht die beschreibung wir
sehen das nur in die minute und noch
nicht mal werden nur verstehen ok hat
gesagt diese beschreibung wir haben das
auf ich stimme dazu
ok wenn die bibliothek zum beispiel
selektion haben wir eine beschreibung
und das ist nicht also komplett und dann
öffnen wir diese lektion wie sehr das
nicht mehr
das meinst du hier und hier fliegt auf
ein teil des anfang und ich nicht
verstehe ich fürchte nur dass hier hast
du ein beschreibung und das ist nicht
komplett und dann wenn diese lektion
öffnet ist das nicht mehr
der erkannte das ist absolut korrekt ja
ja ja ich stimme zu ich werde das mit
macht
du hast hier nichts keine keine
beschreibung du hast eine beschreibung
auf die auf die kurse aber nicht die
nation durch stimme ich nehme dazu
okay wir werden darüber sprechen und
sehen was was zu tun ist
ich habe die die frage ich habe die
probleme gut verstanden und auch was
okay und was auch fehlt ist wenn leute
einen kommentar abgeben mit den rosen
man findet ihr nie mehr es wäre schön
wenn diese kommentar über die lektion
auch lesbar wäre ich sehe dort zum
beispiel eine lektion hat fünf rosen und
bei manchen wird ja dann auch ein
kommentar mit dazu geschrieben warum
einem die lektion gefallen hat und diese
kommentare das sehr viel eher auf ok ich
wünsche und woher sie verziert drei
rosen aber vielleicht hat jemand etwas
geschrieben
ok ich werde ja weil es gibt leute die
die anschauen
also ich finde dass wir das nicht sehen
wollen und ich werde das ein bisschen
wiederholen gibt leute die nicht
verstehen was wir was wir sagen wir
haben die möglichkeit hier hosen zu zu
das heißt dir gefällt diese lektion bla
bla bla und dann kann ich hier ein einer
rot schicken
okay diese kommentar ich stimme dazu das
wäre schön sein das zu sehen wie ich es
war ein kommentar wir haben leute
wollten wissen wer hat mir ein geschenk
dass auch wir werden das war
wir haben eine ganz lange liste von
dingen das wissen aber dass das wir
haben schon bestimmt dass wir werden
diese funktion machen dass du wirst
wissen wer hasst dich ein rose geschenkt
aber jetzt sagst du es wäre schön wenn
diese kommentar schreibe etwas schreibt
etwas auch nie hört zu diese lektion
was meinst du oder habe ich fest
okay okay und wo wurde wo denkst du das
wär das schön also wo sollen wir das
diese kommentare auf dem forum oder man
könnte genau wie eben ist so eine box
aufgesprungen waren veröffentlichen also
beim geben eine rose könnte man genauso
wenn man vielleicht dass die vier klebt
das dann auch so eine box aufspringt mit
scrollbalken wo man die kommentare lesen
könnte ist nur so eine idee
also will ich auch so machen fällen ist
auch da also wo hier also ich habe nicht
verstanden wo sollen wir diese diese
wenn man auf die vier klickt im moment
passiert wahrscheinlich nicht dass man
gleich dort klickt und dann erscheint
auch so eine box mit kommentaren und
wenn man nach veröffentlichen klicken
wobei das wort veröffentlichen ist
vielleicht anderen noch
verbesserungsfähig
irgendwie das problem ist hanspeter da
es sich oft nur ein wort ab das soll ich
einzeln übersetzen
dieses wort taucht dann noch an zehn
verschiedenen stellen in link auf mit
unterschiedlichen bedeutungen ist eine
schwierige
die deutsche grammatik von der
englischen abweicht okay aber ich glaube
das ist eine sehr gute idee und ich
werde darüber mit marc trennen das ist
ein sehr guter wie wollen die leute
ermutigen entmutigen also rosen zu
schicken war das ist sehr wichtig weil
sehr wenig leute also nicht sehr wenig
alles zu wenig leute schicken hosen wenn
mehrere leute werde das magnum das hilft
die andere mitglieder also die die die
also die gute lektionen zu finden und
alles das hilft in diese rose fragen es
ist sehr willkommen also ich werde
darüber mit marc prätsch ok und herren
wir hören also und die probleme die die
mitglieder haben bieten sagt vorschläge
und ein problem weil also ich meine in
der bibliothek heute besuchen das zu
verbessern und auch hans-peter gesagt
dass er hat nicht gern diese neue
lektion seite gesagt diese seite hier
nimmt zu viel platz und das besonders
für chinesisch oder japanisch sind diese
vision die schreibung ist zu klein und
er will an die möglichkeit haben nur
diese die dieser seite hier die idee und
ein bisschen größer zu machen ich ich
ich würde einstimmen ich habe auch
probleme wenn ich japanische stunden
studieren ist die schreibung ein
bisschen zu klein und ich ich kann nicht
die das fenster
min minder machen ohne dass diese rechte
seite wird und dass das ist ein problem
obwohl ich muss schon sagen dass ich die
die lektionen in der bibliothek ich habe
ich habe viel mehr in den lecks in den
letzten wochen studiert ich habe es
interessanter gefunden obwohl es
komplizierter geworden ist habe ich viel
mehr interessantes material gefunden das
ich vorher nie gefunden wurde
ich habe aber nicht würde ich fände ich
hätte es nicht gefunden wie gefunden
aber es scheint dass die die neue
lektion empfehlungen viele neue material
are trade stadt vom bottom herumgeworfen
es ist allerdings komplizierter geworden
doch ich habe sehr viel neues material
gefunden und ich ich bin ich wird neuer
ermutige mutig mutig genug material zu
studieren ich bin arm
ich bin froh ich bin aber ich glaube
nicht der blüte ist es so vorher weiß
sehr schwer dinge zu finden
aber wir waren gewöhnt gewohnt ja ich es
wird halt der wir sind nicht gewohnt und
wie findet das sehr schwierig sehr
kompliziert und es gab sehr viele
probleme sehr viel
ich hatte es aufgeben ab ich habe es
aufgegeben
ich hatte es aufgegeben neue material in
der bibliothek zu suchen
und jetzt suche ich neuer material in
der fremdsprachen
also es wird schon noch besser und sie
können immer die search box am oben
verwendet das funktioniert ganz gut
aber wie soll ein bisschen nur auf die
lektion seite sprechen
ich glaube die bibliothek wir können
noch einmal darüber sprechen wir
versuchen dass die probleme zu lösen und
auch das ein bisschen besser und und
freundliche zu machen aber ich bin
überzeugt überzeugten dass es vieles
dann ist es nicht einfach wir haben so
viele verschiedene dinge so viele
verschiedene also inhalt ist so viele
verschiedene bedingungen wenn man etwas
so das ist nicht einfach
das ist auch nicht einfach auf youtube
etwas zu suchen
das kann ich auch nicht machen
ja ja es wird nicht so einfach das ist
nicht einfach aber wir werden also alle
meinungen hören und versuchen das am
besten zu machen
okay ich habe verstand sie wollen die
möglichkeit haben diese schreiben um
größer zu machen ohne dass diese
oberland probleme oder anderen problemen
entscheiden ich möchte also entlassen
will
ich finde darüber mit die programmlisten
und marc sprechen und sehen was wir
machen eine dinge
diese zweiseitige seite im prinzip okay
wir hatten probleme leute wollten nicht
diese auto scrollfunktion deswegen haben
wir wie sie haben die möglichkeit nicht
auto zu machen okay okay wie man das
verwendet also das ist immer schwierig
war ich habe ich habe meine weise wer
ans bett teilen
adam hat sie haben alle seine also weise
den link zu benutzen und wir mussten
besuchen nach also die tweedy die
majorität was was ist besser die für die
meisten und können wir auch für die
minderheit auch etwas machen und das ist
immer diese problem das wir haben ok
diese ich finde ich werde jetzt diese
zweiseitige seite verteidigen
ok ich finde dass es gibt sehr viele
notwendige dinge hier auf die rechte
seite
wenn das sehr notwendig ich benutze
diese diese platz war wie ich werde auch
verschiedene wörter besucher begrüßen
können
ich kann und ich finde diese beispiele
sehr sehr nutzbar
ich glaube es gibt sehr viele leute die
nicht benutzten diese also automatische
beispiele aber für mich sind sie
fantastisch und ich kann noch immer
diese also ändern und wenn ich kann das
auch edith nicht bereich kann zum
beispiel schönermark deswegen auf meine
flaschen habe ich gute also wie sagt man
phrasen oder fressnapf und ich finde das
schön
ich kann ausdrücke ich kann auch eine
ich kann zum beispiel in der
wörterbücher kann ich auch zum beispiel
verschiedene dramatische erfahrungen
finden und dann kann ich das kopieren
und ich kann das auch meine anmerkung
dann kopieren und ich verwende das okay
vielleicht gibt es leute die überhaupt
nicht diese verwendet
oder auch hier kamen die textstellen es
gab leute die wollen mehrere platz haben
für die hinweise oder für die idee also
phrasen es gibt verschiedene leute die
oder hier kann man auch die status
ändern
ich finde das sehr nutzbar aber es gibt
leute die glauben das nicht
dann müssen wir immer also ein
kompromiss finden aber für mich ich
finde das sehr bitter
manchmal haben die produktion also er
dann sagt man über übersetzung ich kann
mein licht also die neue wörter liest
oder die linke damit ich finde das sind
aber und da das ich verbrauche nicht und
ich ist dass das gesagt dass das ist
nicht so richtig diese facebook aber
dass das ist nicht dass das wie sagt man
dass das ein thema das ist nicht das
nimmt nicht so viel platz aber
vielleicht können wir das wir werden
versuchen diese weil ich finde auch die
breite hier das ist die gewöhnliche
breite auf verschiedene zeitungen auf
internet was ich nicht besonderes das
ist ganz typisch für uns und ich habe
mich vorher wenn das zu breit war habe
ich immer schwierigkeiten die nächste
die nächste besagt man dann erst die
nächste und ich finde das bequemer aber
jeder hat seine weise er hat seine
meinung
wir müssen die dich also die ihr kommen
den namen infinite wir haben ein neues
mitglied geklappt aber jetzt bin ich
hier
wir waren zusammen in berlin
amerika habe ich studiere jetzt in
berlin
ok
sehr schön irgendwo er also frage über
diese wir werden also ich sage nicht an
später dass du nicht recht hat
ich sage nur es gibt auch andere meinung
warum diese zweiseitige seite es besser
ist ich glaube es gibt viel heutigen
auch das nicht schön findet aber da darf
ich einen satz dazu sagen würde die
linke seite etwas schmaler machen und
diese länder auch etwas schmaler machen
um noch etwas platz
zusätzlich zu haben du meist diese blaue
nur neun kleine ja dass sein land den
kann man eigentlich auch etwas enger
machen also diese blaue rande ein
bisschen schmaler machen
es ist unten wie gesagt dass dieses
gesamte teil fenster auch etwas schmaler
machen um leuten die nicht so einen
schönen breiten bildschirm haben
man sieht da noch die möglichkeit zu
geben dann auch mit dem rechten fenster
was man wahrscheinlich jetzt kaum
schmaler machen kann außer durch diese -
schaltfläche ja also man braucht ja das
ist das ist etwas was ich fast immer
genutzt wenn ich nicht gerade vokabeln
nachschlagen
also sie haben die möglichkeit die leute
die haben also schmale also wird man
kleinere türme weder mit screens dann
können sie das minimieren das auch und
es gibt auch leute die bevorzugen die
pop-ups findet die papas nicht schön
weil es verstört mal ich kann nicht
lesen wenn ihr die die papst als die
post dann haben sie die möglichkeit
meine tochter ist jetzt zwölf jahre alt
und sie lernt ja auch mit link nicht
immer aber immer mal wieder und die
villa ist immer so haben also sie findet
das mit dem pop ups wesentlich schöner
und sie stört das oder irritiert das
ungemein beim lesen wenn rechts dieses
große fenster geöffnet ist also sie
findet es mit dem pop ups viel schöner
und ich persönlich mag das auch mich
stört es dann nur in dem moment wenn ich
das wörterbuch öffne zack habe ich
wieder das große fenster da muss es
nachher wieder extra schließen
deswegen fand ich die alte variante
eigentlich schöner ich benutze gerade
für französisch oft leo org
und da habe ich das problem wenn ich das
wörterbuch öffnet das ich immer wollen
muss nach unten und nach rechts also in
zwei richtungen damit ich den inhalt
lesen kann und ich würde es schön finden
wenn man fixieren könnte von der seite
aus dass man einfach sagt link blättert
bei diesem lexikon automatisch 15 hoch
weil oben immer fünf zeilen irgendwelche
dinge stehen die mich nicht
interessieren
du hattest eben reverso zum beispiel
auch dass es wunderbar aber bei anderen
lexika bist du wirklich das problem dass
du immer rollen muss und es ist so zeigt
auch aber nicht unglücklich ich fürchte
aber dass wieder ich das verstehen das
kommt drauf an wie unser wurde also wie
man sich vernetzt mit diesel sagt mainka
nackt mit wiese wörterbuch das glück
dass er das kommt drauf an wie diese
wörter burgweg vigener diese website
nach diesem wörterbuch und dann ist
kommt drauf an wie das alles auf diese
wörterbuch geordnet ist dass das kennen
wir nicht bestimmen ja aber
aber der programmierer könnte sagen ich
zeige das fenster erst ab dieser
position an das kann man bei einem
programm mit sicherheit bestimmen
wir haben so oft wir haben 20 sprache
und verschiedene bücher
verschiedene wörterbücher von chinesisch
japanisch spanisch
es ist ein bisschen schwierig alles
diese verschiedene bedingungen
bedingungen zu zu zu optimieren
aber man müsste es einmal in einer
datenbank hinterlegen ab welche was die
startposition sein sollte könnte das
dann immer nehmen das ist eine einmalige
einstellung das muss man ja nicht jedes
mal geld noch betreffend seien in dem
moment wenn ich ein wörterbuch
hinzufügen
eine bestimmte sprachkombinationen dann
erstelle ich diesen eintragen was mir
überhaupt bei link auffällt ist dass die
fenster breite die ich überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt wird von windows ich kann
ja die fenster verschieden groß machen
kleiner oder größer verändert aber die
anzeige bei link nicht wirklich also da
werden diese css stylesheet richtig
ausgenutzt habe ich das gefühl das habe
ich bei anderen webseiten nicht wenn ich
da das fenster größer oder kleiner
machen passt sich die anzeige auch
besser an als bei link also ich glaube
dort könnte man auch noch optimieren
gerade auf der lektionen seite noch
einmal gemeistert jetzt sprechen wir
nicht über über wörterbücher sondern
über diese seite unserer seite genau
wenn ich jetzt mein fenster breiter
machen
warum wird es nicht insgesamt breiter
wenn ich mein fenster schmaler mache
warum würde es nicht insgesamt schmaler
wenn man als es passt nicht flexibel
genug in meinen augen es ist darum
design her also da kenne ich andere
webseiten sind flexibler ich mein
zuhause habe ich das problem nicht haben
24 zoll monitor aber ich arbeite auch
manchmal mit kleineren bildschirm oder
ich mache das fenster kleinen das können
die sicherheit aber wir haben ein
problem das wir müssen gibt wir haben
nicht die möglichkeit alle probleme zu
lösen und alles alle alle dinge sie ist
auch die kleine lösungen sss es nimmt
zeigt das wird nicht so in 20 sekunden
das kann sein das kann zwei stunden
sein problem seien alle zwei tage und
das wissen wir nicht und wir müssen wir
haben eine ganze reihe dinge die wir
versuchen zu verbessern zum beispiel wie
wir wissen dass wir haben probleme in
der bibliothek und dass alle leute die
benutzten link sie haben problem wenn
sie kann könne nicht die die lektionen
in die bibliothek findet aber es gibt
einige die haben kleine schirm es ja und
es gibt eine also minderheit
wir wollen auch diese probleme lösen
aber wir müssen wir versuchen immer die
idee die probleme die idee besagt
affektiert die meisten leute und ich
habe jetzt also alle diese meinung
bemerken sie habe das geschrieben wir
werden versuchen das ein bisschen zu
verbessern aber ich kann ich kann ich
kann ich also wir haben herr beschränkte
ressourcen mehrere anmerkungen über den
bibliothek oder oder unser also ich muss
sagen dass für mich und das ist
vielleicht es gibt viele leute auch sie
finden dass zum beispiel jetzt wenn ich
versuche ich mache also sehr schnell
ich finde das sehr schön ich kann lesen
und auf die rechte seite sehe ich also
die idee die die meinung für mich ist
das bequem aber das kann es kann sein
auch dass ich verstehe es gibt leute
endes nicht nur wäre oder deine doch es
gibt auch leute die ich finde das nicht
so schön es ist mein kompromiss weil es
gibt verschiedene weise verschiedene
meinungen
wir versuchen immer die die die große
teile unserer mitglieder dazu sei das
frei
ich habe zu viel zu früh sich in meinem
kopf so zufrieden zu machen oder zu
fliegen
okay du hast du eine noch einige
kommentare oder ja ich kann natürlich
nicht so im detail sommer dinge
beschreiben weil ich eigentlich sehr
aktiv mit koproduzieren von broadcast
bin und ich benutze eigentlich link zum
selber lernen nur gelegentlich und dann
auch nur dass ich mir sage mal podcast
anhören und in das transkript dazu lese
parallel aber also die eigentliche
detailarbeit mit den linken
da habe ich jetzt zum beispiel ein
bisschen jetzt ausprobiert links zu
kreieren
aber ich bin damit eigentlich überhaupt
nicht klar gekommen das war mein
computer fing an zu hängen und und
irgendein skript musste dann sich da
muss ich da irgendwie was wegklicken und
das ist was man mir also und zu
unhandlich das ganze system ich hatte
2009 hat sich neu war auf der linken
seite hatte ich sehr viele links
erarbeitet und da war konnte ich einfach
dass eine nach dem anderen machen und
auch da gut mitarbeiten aber jetzt
scheint es also von der funktionalität
fünf verändert zu sein dass das ich dann
persönlich nicht okay also die die wenn
man verwendet dede die zweiseitige seite
dann ist es wo man man ja jetzt habe ich
nicht autos crowe und ich dann brauche
ich beginne ich auf eine blaue lager das
heißt also es gibt daneben
das wort haben diese vorschläge sind
oder vorschläge von unserer mitglieder
und manchmal ist es ein vorschlag von
von google translate oder man kann auch
suchen in dem wörterbuch
aber ich also von deutsch zu englisch
oder spanisch zu englisch russisch zu
englisch sind die hinweise von unserer
mitglieder 90 prozent gut oder google
translate aber ich finde für japanisch
oder chinesisch translate überhaupt
nicht nutzbar und es kann sein auch dass
die übersetzung nach den superpreis auch
nicht benutzbar ist aber auch dazu
nämlich kein problem und deswegen hatte
die lok ist kann sein dass die ich
meistens zum beispiel deutschsprachiger
sprache sie werden immer die die
wörterbuch anwenden und wenn sie seine
lieblingsorte buch anwendet dann wenn
die wird die die hinweise von anderen
mitglieder immer besser sein aber für
mich ich es geht ganz schnell ich klicke
nur zu erbitten
und dann sehe ich immer die frage ob das
will ich nicht haben weil es ist kein
wort das ist ein platz dann ex ok und
sauber will ich nicht haben ex und und
so weiter ok eines geld ganz schnell für
mich und ich über du sagst ex worauf
drückst du einsatz
okay hier haben naja aber hier haben sie
die keyword shortcuts links oder rechts
shift das ist wechsel zwischen bauern
und gärten worden
und hier schiffs und echsen das ist
nicht nur ihre ja okay ist ein wort ist
bekannt und es ist so haben wir die
wende
nicht deine maus verwendet will wenn
verwenden will da kannst du hier diese
keyboard kannst verwenden
okay so du kannst entente das haben wir
auch den jetzt gemacht war
wenn ich mir zum beispiel auf 1 hier
komme ich und wenn ich klicken klick
dann gedroht haben das ist der nächste
nächsten zwei mal geklickt aber wenn du
will nicht sofort aber zu der nächste
wort gern dann kannst du shift entern
und dann läufst du da
das große problem dass ich schon bei den
nächsten oder übernächsten wortwahl wo
ich mit dem ersten wort noch nicht
fertig war
dann musst du schiff nicht gesprungen
und ohne dass ich da schon etwas
eingegeben hat über dem ersten wort
ok dann musste schiff center machen dann
zb dann gehen wir einmal an
ok also ich mache das nie ich gehe zur
nächsten board aber vielleicht wirst du
diese wort arbeiten sehen dann gehst du
schiff entern und das damit bleibst du
da und dann hatte ich noch ein problem
und zwar habe ich also sag mal die texte
die ich nehme die sind auf spanisch habe
aber als networking language english
eingestellt bewusst weil ich warte ich
über die fremdsprache das lernen möchte
partie ich bekomme dann die englischen
übersetzung vorgeschlagen möchte aber
zum teilen die englischen möchte ich
natürlich sehen da geht es wieder
drohnen aber ich möchte zum teil noch
ist gleich zeichen hinzufügen und dann
noch die ein deutsches wort aus meinem
papier wörterbuch noch dazu schreiben
dass ich dankbar tisch das spanische
wort hat mit der englischen und
deutschen übersetzung gleichzeitig und
das möchte ich dann eintragen so möglich
dass dann auch in der liste stehen haben
und das scheint irgendwie nicht zu
funktionieren manchmal steht dann gehts
englische wort ich bin was einfachen da
kann ich aber nichts rein getrampelt
und dann gebe ich das dann auch auf und
ab dann keine lust mehr
man muss seine also wörterbuch sprache
bestimme stimmen bestimmen
entweder ich möchte die standardsprache
englisch haben weil ich die englischen
sorgte er gleich mit lernen möchte und
dann nehme ich meine papier wert der
bücher die ich hier liegen habe und dann
suche ich mir noch ein spanisches wort
sagen meinen deutschen den deutsche
übersetzung zusätzlich aus das ist was
mich dreisprachig die index verarbeitet
und so möchte ich jetzt mache keine
machen weil hier
ok auf englisch heißt das neue sieger
maria und das noch dazu schreiben
dann will ich dass dazu schreiben und
dann kann ich das nicht da rein füllen
weil das war das nicht anklickbar ist
kann ich diese soll daher das wegnehmen
und deutschland ich will das englische
das will ich hier haben dass ich werde
nicht okay englische und richtig mache
das nie aber ich werde versuchen deutsch
und hier schreiben wir also test etwas
und ender ok und dann gern wie zurück zu
englisch an das ist okay
alles ist hier praktisch mir ein
englisches wort vorgeschlagen dass
billig zu haben das finde ich in ordnung
und dann möchte ich dass das anklickt
wahr ist dass ich noch an its place
zeichen der zufüge und dann auch aus dem
papier wörterbuch mental spanisches wort
daran kippe wie man deutsches wort
ich glaube es gibt sehr wenig leute die
haben diese entsprachen forum auf auto
lernen in die linken bestellt aber das
ist eine minderheit problem auch link
wir haben hier diese wir haben hier die
möglichkeit weil es gibt leute die haben
zum beispiel englisch als muttersprache
und sie stellen hier eine japanische
übersetzung und manchmal sehen wir eine
besetzung das ist das nicht englisch ist
und deswegen können wir her die die
sprache ändern
und da ich glaube das ist die meinung
dieser funktion weil wir wollen nicht in
die in die hinweise die rigiden von
mitglieder wollen wir nicht hinweise
hier haben die nicht englisch ist oder
auf deutsch nur deutsche oder wie
abartig nur japanisch deswegen avastin
flut ab dafür was dazu sagen du kannst
auf das pluszeichen klicken rechts von
der von dem tag ja dann kommt kann man
eine neue sprache noch hinzufügen
vielleicht ist das interessant für das
das problem ist das macht man selten
aber das ist ein dankeschön hans-peter
sowieso da kann man eine zusätzliche
sprache einstellen um die übersetzung
noch in einer anderen sprache sich auf
zu beschreiben
es gibt so viele funktionen auf linke
ich verwende dich da die funktion ist
das letztendlich nicht nachhaltig man
kann sogar bilder speichern
ich wollte nur sagen man kann sogar
bilder speichern indem man da oben in
das bild auf das pluszeichen klickt kann
man den lauf
nur das ist noch aufwändiger meine drei
sprachen haben wir will ich nicht das
ist halt meine natalie hast du eine
frage oder kommentar also ich habe
gerade angefangen die geringste day zu
benutzen
und ich habe es zu 50 gestellt aber ich
weiß nicht ob ich ihn die ideale
bekommen aber für die karten mindestens
sind bis normalerweise nummer 29 oder
einmal was 32 nur weiß nicht warum also
es kommt darauf an dass ich diese dinge
dass ich bin nicht zu also ich kriege
immer meine 25
aber ich glaube es kommt drauf an wie
viel neue link du hast gemacht weil wir
haben eine so genannte algerischem aber
es am besten wenn du fragst am form
dann wird mag oder also das erklären
weil ich kann ich kann das nicht
ja das ist die einzige sache okay wir
haben schon ganz lange gesprochen hast
du etwas zu sagen ich habe gestern
anerkannt das ist ein problem in der am
lernen seite gibt wenn man schnell
linken will kann man auf einen tag am
tippen ja aber manchmal springt link
eine gewürze und da musste ich
zurückgehen und das ist mit importierte
texte wir haben das problem es gibt wie
sagt man format in verschiedene seite
zum beispiel zeitungen und dass wir
versuchen jetzt diese formate zu
vernichten
aber wwe ist es ein problem lieber wir
wissen dass es dass es existiert es gibt
manchmal seite
die haben eine gewisse form erding und
unser
wenn wir schnell linken dass man genau
dann werde das überspringen können wir
versuchen das zu etwas zu machen
ich bin normalerweise ich anwender die
die seite mit autos und wenn ich habe
solche seite weil ich im portals sehr
viel ab und koreanisch dann werden die
autos kohl wegnehmen
okay aber wir versuchen diese formaten
zu zu vernetzen vernichten
und dann werden wir nicht die dieses
problem haben wir haben eine neue
mitglieder wir werden schon von ihr
gehirn gibt es andere probleme oder ist
nicht mehr mein sind ja sie mussten
okay die ta zinstief ich bin zurück nach
links links kann man einstellen dass man
rechts auf der seite
wir haben wir heute den beschriebenen
kunden
ich sehe das nicht klären wir haben
extra 10 aber ich sehe nichts nichts ist
ein blaues feldstetten und das muss blau
sein - kaum ist dann kann man den chat
rechts nicht lesen aber ist blau und ich
sehe ich sehe etwas geschrieben
geschlossen nein ich sehe nichts
deswegen sehe ich nicht ich habe meinen
bildschirm freigegeben
screenshot machen und hier links kannst
du auf chat klicken
ich sehe nur verzerrt okay aber ich sehe
nichts gar nichts nichts ok ich will
untersuchen warum ich kann keine chat
sehen weil ich glaube es gibt auch
manchmal leute die nicht also teilnehmen
sie wollen vielleicht auch kommentar
schicken aber dann wären die chat zum
beispiel dazu benutzt auch mal eine
korrektur
nein zu schreiben das sind okay aber
jedem gefalle ich glaube wir haben ganz
lange gesprochen hat das ist vielleicht
in deutschland schon heute in england
abendessen
ich danke für dieses gespräch
es war sehr interessant sie haben sehr
viel geduld mit meinen schlechte deutsch
und wir werden
ich hoffe wir werden das noch einmal
machen und ich habe sehr viele aus
homburg hier und ich werde darüber mit
mark wir werden sehen was wir machen
kann
ok danke schön